[Musique]
nous retrouverons comme chaque lundi
michaël et demi d'euros en plateau
bonjour michael bonsoir et on parle de
sport il y avait du basket ce week end
playoffs
c'est ça la basket américain français
c'est ça l'entente le chesnay-versailles
peut jubiler le fcb 78 réussi à éviter
une revente à d'assaut samedi 18 mai sur
son teint en quarts de finale de
prénationale vainqueur 73 à 50 2 à
l'aller face à paris 14 les hommes de la
cité royale se sont imposés au retour 81
à 71 sur leur parquet on écoute les
réactions il fallait être concentré
respecté les consignes et jouer au
basket voilà tous les matches qu'il faut
gagner
donc même si on était à + 21 ans on
puisse prendre donc 2
c'était de gagner l'objectif c'était
véritablement de jouer pour gagner et
surtout pas de jouer pour ne pas perdre
et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait du coup ça a
fait un match plein voilà ils se sont
défendus avec leurs armes et on a encore
été plus fort ce soir donc c'est
amplement mérité je pense
avec ce résultat l'entente le chesnay
versailles 78 de se qualifier pour le
final four de la division l'équipe
affrontera meudon en demi-finale sur
terre un autre appareil pas d eau pour
une revanche dans deux semaines les me
donner les avait battus au mois de
février dernier en cas de victoire les
joueurs de la cité royale se verrait
propulsé en nationale 3 et après le
basket le football championnat de
régionale 3 trappe à peut-être laissé
passer sa chance pour remporter le titre
mais l'équipe a fait un grand pas vers
la montée les trappistes ont pu faire
mieux que match nul 1 but partout à 6
heures sur le terrain de rueil malmaison
un résultat qui leur permet d'être
deuxièmes à une journée de la fin du
championnat le strap conserve trois
points d'avancé sur son adversaire du
jour et un match nul le week-end
prochain pourrait leur offrir la montée
wilfrid merci michael pour ce tour
d'horizon des résultats du week end sur
les yvelines on vous retrouve dans
quelques instants pour le 7-8 sport et
un point à beaucoup plus complet sur
l'actualité sportive